believing you can and you will a mindset
for the students in the first all-girls
public charter school in nevada the
young women's leadership academy of las
vegas near desert inn and pecos opened
its doors for female students grades 6
through
victoria saha gives us a closer look at
how this school aims to change many
young girls lives
[Music]
being surrounded by only female peers is
a new concept for many of these students
here at the young women's leadership
academy of las vegas but as they wrap up
their first week of school many are
realizing this is exactly what they
needed to succeed
every morning principal whitney mcintosh
gathers the 6th and ninth graders in a
circle circles are a shape that's not
easily broken
in that unbroken circle goals for the
day are discussed and letting the almost
70 students know together they have what
it takes to achieve them we focus on how
we present ourselves and then we also
provide them opportunities to advocate
the young women's leadership academy is
located on the east side of town where
opportunities are limited for many we're
just making sure that we're tearing down
every barrier so that students receive
the access that they need starting with
giving them a voice i realize i can
actually talk up and i can actually be
more present in the class because i had
a class
last year that i didn't even talk in
because i was so scared i feel like we
all could make a difference one day
doing something amazing the school has a
rich history the founder and tisch
started the network of the young women's
leadership school also known as twills
in 1996.
east harlem new york was the first
location then several opened throughout
the city including astoria queens where
my twin sister and i were part of the
first graduating class in 2013. paying
attention to the young woman and really
making sure that it's not just academics
that makes them successful but also a
community of support and sisterhood and
although graduation day may seem far
away principal mcintosh is already
dreaming big for her scholars knowing
the direction that they want to go
making sure every one of them has access
to college and that they have a definite
path and they know they have a community
of support because they all have what it
takes to be leaders of tomorrow the
school is currently enrolling 50 more
students all year long and you do not
have to live in the east valley to
attend
victoria saha 8 news now
with their college bound initiative
nearly 100 percent of the students who
attend this school go to college
registration for 6th and 9th graders is
now open for this fall